in five four three two is the busted
busty you can show off your inner weird
hello and welcome everybody to the
BuzzFeed stay home talent show
my name is yoni lotin I am Taylor Ortega
and I'm John Trowbridge we are your
hosts and your judges extraordinaire so
house is gonna go down we have six
amazing performers who are gonna come
and visit us in this webcam they have
five minutes to perform their talent and
the three of us will judge them fairly
on three categories one actual talent to
creativity and three a simple Jeunesse a
quoi you know that at an essence you
know each person brings a little bit of
their own personality into it
we'll be judging that scoring will be on
a scale from one to ten and I'm calling
it now I doubt anyone's getting a
perfect
I'm sorry we're very discerning right no
you're very right we're very nice people
and we want you guys to have a good time
and spread joy but we're also just not
gonna hand out tens to just like anybody
you know we try to maintain some
credibility for the show so we will be
we will be harsh but we will be fair
like this is a serious talent show and
and we we've hand-picked these people to
perform for the buzzfeed audience
speaking of talents right have you
developed any talents
well I'm I'm a Michelin star chef it
only took two months but I've actually
turned into a Michelin star chef to the
degree of your Gordon Ramsay's and I
can't name any more chefs so I am as
good as Gordon Ramsay yeah I've gotten
really good at marinating Stinky's what
about you guys oh well um I did teach
myself how to play guitar it's fine oh
that's huge
well I don't know is it
yeah I mean deck watching Sopranos so
yeah that's my I could burp on command
cool
that's yeah so why are we doing this
talent show number one we love to judge
number two times are hard we're stuck
inside we can't go out you shouldn't go
out but we'd like to share a little joy
like what people are doing in their
homes to keep themselves happy and to
keep themselves entertained that's right
it's important to count the little joys
and or in our case the very very big
Joy's that you're about to see
absolutely talented people that are
gonna do some are actually pretty insane
stuff and maybe it will inspire you to
maybe try out that secret talent that
you've been wanting to do for a long
time big shout out to shot BuzzFeed for
helping us put all this together right
now everything in the shop is 30% off
and during the show 50% of proceeds go
to Coba to relief so use code talent if
you want that drap are you ready to see
some people do some talents I'm like a
webcam wish okay let's get started with
our first island
[Music]
nothing are you I'm here to satisfy your
long-lost beatboxing needs thank you
it's been a minute
right now upstate New York we cannot
wait to see your talent what are you
gonna be doing for us tonight
Jonathan had a couple of ideas play
handpan guitar but I think beatboxing is
definitely my thing it's like a little
it's it's half drum half just beautiful
tonal notes you've probably heard it in
like a meditation or a yoga class before
bath or sound bath there you go trendy
John nice I've been to Burning Man a
couple times so it's my lifestyle and
what I like to do hilarious how much
they've accidentally paired up paired us
up perfectly
kindred spirits so as you please give us
a delicious little sound bath right now
and show us your talent I actually put
two medleys together so I wanted to make
this a bit of a choose your own
adventure for you guys are you feeling
more kind of like upbeat dance or more
kind of like sexy R&B 90's hip hop vibes
keep it sexy beautiful
judges in the past number two all right
sounds good let's do it
that's dick all right we'll put
ourselves on meat so we can hear the
sexy sounds beautiful beautiful here we
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do it
Mon Albu it do it more now boots do it
slow now Butte buzzfeed are you ready to
get funky yeah
the beat the beat and the chorus - thank
you so much as had sex in three months
[Laughter]
we won't get into the fact the
quarantine zone Leben two months yeah
he's being like well it's crazy that
Nova's having sex right we're like yeah
you just keep bringing it up I like to
connect with my friends and I think
but enough about Johnson we're going to
do the group therapy session for John
afterwards yeah he needs it that was
that was one of the most intense
experiences I've ever had I mean so
we're gonna so we're gonna judge you
like I said before on you know raw
talent creativity juice a quad that
x-factor I'm just gonna go ahead right
up top they give you a full ten it was
the easiest decision I've ever made in
my life I've seen usually it maybe she's
my experience but whenever someone's
like I'm gonna beat bucks for you I
prepare myself to be disappointed and
you did not you did I think six sounds
at one time which I so for that alone
and of course you have the x-factor and
I feel a personal kinship to you because
we're the same exact person you could
attend for me right up - the three
months of no sex thing it was amazing
for me I loved it but but based on the
fact that we're not twins from the
mountains I like you and I'm gonna do an
eight are you the Simon Cowell of the
trio no not even
wow-wow-wow
simply Wow I was blown away by it and I
remember trying to beatbox also and it
like like I could burp on command well I
guess the closest I got to no no
and you my friend you my friend brought
me back to that moment but I have a
record
I have a reputation to know you're the
Simon Cowell that's right less than an
eighth you mean I'm gonna give you a ten
[Music]
when you see you see talent and you
gotta call it like you see it you know
and you know what where I stand about
sticking the landing my friend you stuck
the landing
great job kudos to you my friend super
where can people hear more of your
absolutely otherworldly p-box it amazing
thank you Jehan hi the plyo truly
provides in this example I appreciate
your man yeah just two quick things is
that Instagram just Jay Stone feel free
to jump on there I post a lot of music
stuff my other major passion besides
music and beatboxing is wellness I
actually run a company called flow and
tell thank you so much for coming on the
show such a pleasure thanks so much guys
[Music]
how's it going how long have you been
been making art with food okay oh wow so
it's Brett it's a fresh staring at my
ceiling creative this is the question
that is very important to me when it
comes to making food into art what is
the essence what is the the me it's
about ephemera I think I'm so used to
working on or it takes so much time
we precious about it and it's really
exciting control and this is a practice
for me creating something that's meant
to be destroyed no I usually I just
photograph it and once I feel like I've
gotten a good shot I'll take it apart
and put like dry-goods back of the box
and oh so you're not wasting the food
does you know I was no joke I was the
whole time I was like you know it's kind
of wasteful of food that's gonna bring
down her score but now they know that
fact that's great okay well that feels
like as good a place as any to jump in
give you the floor and take it away show
us your talent so we don't know what
painting you're doing yet we're gonna be
surprised
we know if we don't yeah yeah hey hey
judges no matter what she shows us
pretend that we know what she's showing
us yeah we're cultured yeah yeah what
are some what are some paintings that we
can just - Mona Lisa obviously important
representation for me as a girl who
looks like Mona Lisa what else what the
bank the bank see where the little girl
is holding a balloon machine gun yeah we
painted the elephant pink and put it in
a warehouse
I miss 2009 so much you guys let's see
what else what else oh the one look at
us trying to name our night the scream
the scream starring um as a girl who
looks like tell me I don't like the
scream okay so we have some colors now
oh wow so let's let's rule out based on
what it is let's rule out some painting
so it's not like Washington Crossing the
Delaware
I don't think which is too bad it's not
a starry night yeah not sorry night when
it comes to colors like what do you
what's it like what's your strategy when
it comes to colors I've just I just
started really quickly that there are
specific colors that are really hard to
replicate because there just aren't a
lot of foods in nature with those colors
yes
dark black is hard except for lentils or
the skin of an eggplant
Wow oh okay okay
Oh see now I automatically no good can
you get a little closer
can we see what so holy crap I think I
know what it is okay yoni go ahead I
believe it's the poster for the movie
the girl it's an ass of Vermeer painting
ass yeah so is it the girl with the
Pearl Earring it's actually the girl
with a PE earring but yes and what did
you use for the black at the bottom so
that's nori just a sheet of seaweed it
made me really hungry another yeah okay
so yoni what do you what do you think
what are you saying
alright so let me preface before I give
you my point score that I am a bit of a
I'm the Simon of the group alright I'm a
little bit of a stickler okay right so
let me first say that this is extremely
you're extremely talented and not any
person could just see an image and
replicate that with items and like I'll
say and welcome and
say the fact that it is food that you
are not wasting its extra points my
however is I wish it was there was a
painting that you didn't do and they in
the live moment but that is neither here
no there I think your talent should be
praised which is why I will be giving
you I'll be giving you and Wow okay
really good for you made us think you're
gonna do one of your classic fives true
talent when we talk Jenna say quoi I
mean this is pretty straightforward
there's nothing like well you know but
this also part of my scoring is how
French is this and to me this is very
French you know and because there's many
interpretations of that phrase so love
that I do wonder why you have so many
healthy groceries do you think you're
better than me so that's the only hot
place where I lost some points Oreos are
dark like you could have used those but
over on so impressed I could never do
this in a million years my hands are
trash and I'm gonna go strong aids
strong eggs and the world's eyes turn to
me yes so and so uh you know like
they've said before this this talent
should be praised I loved I loved
watching you do it I love the final
product I love that it's a thing that
like you know if I'm if I'm somebody I'm
gonna like I'm gonna pick this up this
is like my new this is my new thing for
me you get a solid eight across the
board there you go that's a great scorn
what is your Instagram or anything you
want people to follow or come see plug
it here and now is salvo thank you for
joining us
what's going on guys what's happening
where are you I'm home you're home okay
yeah you see my love lights I had to you
know with my lights in the wall and
stuff you know it's kind of make it guys
presentable for you guys you know yeah
it looks like you're in front of a
frosted window in front of like a
cityscape this is like it's like in a
music video type situation oh I do see
that like rainwater situation legal army
vibes yeah a fan fans gonna change your
life I'll tell you what's that so you
are essentially you're gonna be doing
some impressions for us today but also
what I love about your talent is you're
doing a commencement speech for all the
kids out there who can't graduate
because the world ended yes world ended
so you're giving them a little something
yeah they deserve it
yeah they need the advice that they're
not gonna get from Mindy Kaling or
whoever would what's yeah here we go
take it away
thank you everyone for joining us here
this afternoon
I am Barack Obama and I am here to give
the 2020 commencement speech usually in
times like these I would be able to look
you in the face I would be able to watch
you walk but lately we have been dealing
with a hindrance and here to talk about
a hindrance is my friend Denzel
Washington I believe now that in a time
like this a hindrance is not something
that would stop us
no a hindrance
something that would delay us or to
obstruct your path now to delay only
simply means that it takes more time to
get the way you need to be like a GPS
huh you understand what I'm saying
okay in a GPS if you make the wrong turn
it only reroutes you so you're gonna get
to your destination I guarantee it I
stand by huh and uh here to talk about
the times that you've spent getting here
as my friend Dave Chappelle hey what's
that I want to say that these are hard
times hard times baby I'm saying you've
got to stay in the game stay in the game
it's serious man when you walk in your
hallways down the streets to your
quarter stars way mask but I tell you
this before you wear your mask brush
your teeth you gotta brush your teeth
feet cuz man what's happening is that
every time your friends are telling you
about your bad breath you experiencing
it personally here to give a speech on
how to recover business-wise none of
them been rapper Kurtis 50 cent Jackson
you know sounds a lot and this that's
just what it is it's not like no it's
really not if you want understand
business-wise it's not enough people
it's gonna be on your level business one
that's is something that you know you
got a nice thin when I first started
doing my show they would give me 18 tell
yes yes I appreciate you guys I
appreciate you so much for allowing me
to come on this platform I'm talking to
Denzel finally you never know huh you
never know what's gonna when it's gonna
happen for you I guarantee I
also heard you do a Stewie Griffin is
that true well you know I have to work
on my students no it's not much better
you know I wanna pursue as far as that
you know I feel like there are certain
accents and certain voices that I do but
they really kind of said it all but you
know I'm just I'm time they can happen
here you know I'm trying to get my money
Brian amazing so in terms of scoring
John you're first right what do you
think right so talent creativity
janessa quoi from me mm-hmm absolutely
stellar performance you get an eighth
for me then and it said very strong you
hit you hit all the all the grapes for
me what what was the most impressive is
the addition of $0.50 a guess we've all
been in the game for 30 40 years yes no
one has a 50-cent impression no nobody
so you sir are setting the tone for the
future of 50 cent impressions here
tonight okay
so I loved it I thought the impressions
were great but also the writing was
great the jokes were there every
impression had a perspective I'm being
too sincere these are all real things I
love it be as sincere as you mean that
was really well done my manager would
love you she'd be like really clean set
Wow
yeah look I got a smart purchase judge I
gotta say no it's true the three of us
actually were all comedians that we all
we have all done impressions of
celebrities and it's true it's like you
know when you hear it it's like I was
closing my eyes and
never heard of 50-cent it was perfect
but yeah look you a nine because look
there's clear passion inside of you
there's passion for this you there's
work and there's effort and there's
passion and it shows you so much plug
plug plug hey guys you guys can follow
me on youtube cking TV you guys can
follow me on instagram i am underscore
ck ing we are about i want to say we're
about two hundred and something people
away from reaching 50 k oh really we got
this train going and you know so i'm
some businesses and do all that stuff I
got my comedy up there of course but I
am underscore ck ing I am underscore ck
ng and cking TV on YouTube I love you
guys thank you so much for the right up
next we have a young man by the name of
Liam he my friends is a trick shot
master that's right basketball trick
shots is this thing so Liam where are
you right now where are you from how are
you feeling
what's up Emma I live in Manhattan
normally I'm from northern New Jersey
and that's where I am right now my
parents house don't know what a trick
shot is Liam can you break it down for
us I would say a trick shot is anything
that deviates from what you would see in
a normal basketball game so one would be
doing it some be good rainbowy them all
off the brick wall
I'm gonna catch it in the in midair and
based on how my body is facing the
basket I'll either throw it backwards or
a hook shot hopefully this is partially
improvised okay write that down write
that down get into account I'm gonna
give myself ten takes quick ten takes
and if I don't make it by then you know
it's a bummer but that's the life of
being a trickshot King here we go take
number one all right so liam is loading
up here
loading it up for the rainbow this is
try number one okay looks good oh my god
out to the beautiful nature of noise and
that's gonna go into account my loading
okay you guys to number three don't
worry that was close I was essentially
in I was basically yeah except for the
back mix okay sure
it's rainbow down oh sure number one is
coming off okay my nickname is the
mailman because my name my name spelled
backwards is mail and I always deliver
so for any other Liam's out there
you now have a nickname if anyone tells
you that you don't deliver they're wrong
you got this Wow that was somewhat
threatening my gosh okay looking good
it's funny there's like a slight delay
yeah maybe it went in okay rainbows up
I remember supremo's good no to mustard
yeah boom this is what we want on it
right tenth try built up the suspense
and I think I need to bring him one more
prop here oh my gosh I'm Tony's been
playing with was
my sister was the basketball star but
she's visually doesn't have great vision
so in fourth grade before context became
a thing
she wore rec specs so yes on the
basketball court he's gonna help me with
the rec specs I
Liam today I'm going to give you a 7 out
of 10 because awesome you connected on
the rainbow every single time the ball
hit garage every single time during
during the you know it was very creative
you took off clothing during it which
had sex factor for me and I think all
the other judges really okay well you
know there's a lot to consider talent
creativity how friendship was and I do
love the rainbow shot I thought that was
something I can't do and also Fridays
canceled this year so go nuts you know
really important I would 24 the talent
alone I gave a six because we didn't
accomplish it but for creativity and
Jenna said wha I'm nine now I know what
you're thinking that sounds like and I
don't know the math that it would
average out to about it an eight but I
John gave you a seven and as the only
female judge and I wish that politics
didn't have to be a part of this but as
the only edge I cannot be known for
niceness or pill addiction so I have to
go I have to go with the seven at best
well I will be known as the one who is
known for pill addiction because of my
pill addiction it's kidding I'm lol we
JK here over here stayed home with that
said what so in terms of creativity my
man you're getting a ten in terms of
genetic Wow
you're getting a tip when it comes to
the talent aspect of it you need you
need to stick the landing so I am gonna
have to give you five oh I thought you
were gonna be the nice judge not today
my friend you know I preciate
constructive criticism will make me
stronger
I'll see you guys next year holy we're
not still home Liam why with that said I
do I do want to say that honestly I bet
you you can make that shot any other
time and I really do appreciate the fact
that you do put in the effort to make
people happy
hold tight because this is you got
pretty good scores from me and John and
you are you know we have a lot of other
contestants to see and we don't know if
they're ass or not so you know ass or
not ya know thank you so much for your
time guys my trickshot channel is at
Sunday's scariest trick shots I post a
trickshot every day try to get people
laughing but yeah I hope you all stay
healthy stay inside and looking forward
to this quarantine to be over so we can
all be back out there together every
talent that we see I it just keeps
getting better and better and I'm
starting to feel insecure because I'm
not as talented as these people let's
please see what's next
hello Ellie this is so great thank you
thank you for coming on stay home talent
show how long have you been a drummer
for since I was about two years old
so about 18 years so now what are you
guys what are you gonna be doing for us
today Willie I'll be performing over one
of my own tracks entitled Seuss oh you
made this last night specifically for
y'all what is the running and dancing in
my personal / professional opinion I
would say creativity like that's a big
factor in everything rather comes to
drumming rather comes to dancing if you
can make your own style out of it have
fun with it always do your best you can
go anywhere you want
I love that positive attitude I love it
all right Willie
and we're just going to let you take it
away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unbelievable unbelievable drumming
drumming music athletics aerobics got
parkour in there unbelievable I mean you
lips so John right what is your official
score
I saw something new I saw something I've
never seen before
I I'm sorry I have to give you a 10
Willie I'm sorry you've been outside I
think that's the most impressive
physical thing I've seen in my career
right like juggled I can't juggle
I can't drum I can't dance I definitely
think that was more than two talents
that was at least there one five talents
in one thing that's not on us more
talents I I you were serving us like it
felt like if Busta Rhymes were made of
wood and you know you don't I mean like
that was the vibe
that's like I couldn't look away for
like I would go to take a note but then
I look back and you'd be doing some
other insane thing which is so creepy
if I do one impressive thing I'm done
for the day I loved it I thought that
was insane Annie was your song like that
above and beyond I have to say Ted like
yes do more thank you oh my god and so
now the world's our world's harshest ER
I mean I want it it's hard for me
because how are people gonna know I'm a
[ __ ] if I get if I keep giving too but
like that was so good so yeah but but
yoni is one of the most cold-hearted
people that anybody's ever met so this
is gonna be the tough one Willie Willie
yes sir I gotta say my friend you are
talented I got it I gotta say it it's
it's incredibly impressive and I think
my friend Taylor said best it felt like
those were multiple talents showing the
song was great again you banged on
something with your lips and also
drumming right you know I'm known here
as the harshest judge and I'm trying
I am trying to think of something to be
harsher about but I can't which mean we
have a triple Ted Willie that's the
first one really that's the first 30
that's the first 3400 Mike I literally I
was stressing all night trying to think
of okay what routes what routine am I
going to do am I just gonna freestyle in
about what tricks am I gonna do I was
freaking out about this all day it all
came together Willie do you plug
something tell the people where they can
see more of you and hear more of you my
Instagram is Willie D a drama kids at
Willie gh Willie does drama kid and I'm
actually better off I like most of my
viewers come from tick-tock so my
tick-tock is Willie dolt drummer but the
three an adult
Willie unbelievable talent unbelievable
performance thank you so much for coming
on the show and we'll be in touch
yeah all right all right easy easy we
did we have more acts to go
[Music]
well next up we have a Molly coming to
town but Molly says that she's a
character named Sean so put your hands
together for Sean I'm just I'm nervous
he's not so attractive wow that's gonna
go it's gonna go into your school scores
going up so Sean we are bringing people
to show us their stay home talents Sean
what is your talent well uh I'm from
Alabama
you know I'm a small town boy raised on
a dairy farm and unfortunately I am
lactose intolerant so uh I have
experienced trouble and in that struggle
I found that I can do impressions now
you may know like celebrity impressions
maybe you've seen like Danny DeVito or
we're maybe Arnold Schwarzenegger but I
don't do those types of impressions I
view other people we all know it's not
find that more relatable okay okay okay
all right I'm on board
I mean if impression is my first
question
all right governor time um this is a guy
taking his dog out I'm really cold not
to Pete whoa Russell come on crazy Pete
already okay this next one it's a trash
guy picking up the trash early in the
morning okay is trash man
okay uh this next one is a woman meeting
her in-laws for the first time at
Thanksgiving Mrs Flynn I am so excited
to be here and you just say I love your
son so much I'm just excited to be a
part of your family okay
this next one is a guy who who loves
pasta okay so I put the gorgonzola is a
woman getting her hair done for the
first time in like 20 years
it's actually mom
was my mom getting I'm here too okay um
this last one is someone whose rings
look okay real good lovin exist okay
yeah I just I am really I love myself
I'm really kind and I just really
important some of those people mm-hmm
not your mom but I did know other other
people hmm let's see well my so my
roommate I'm living with right now he
brought in his girlfriend to live with
us
and she has been playing a lot of piano
and singing and singing most most nights
Megan that was that was nearly identical
well right I have I have a wrench in
your plan my friends what if my uncle
was very DeVito can you do an impression
of my uncle Danny DeVito he is a
character actor but right now during
quarantine he's mowing the lawn a lot
with him pretty good
it's pretty good
actually runs on my social media her
name is Molly I love your head is that
Sean alright so do you guys feel right
page four points yeah so we're gonna
we're gonna grade you on creativity
talent and a jeunesse a quoi and we're
gonna should we just give you the score
and you'll relay it to your brother
that's fine yeah he's actually in one of
the fields now I can't get him wait
alright snow Taylor me I loved it I felt
like I recognized a lot of people so for
me the impressions were right on love
that I also loved Sean's energy I love
that he has been through something and
that he has seen struggle 7.54 the
quality of the talent I'm obviously you
know Sean's strength for me is holding
up a mirror to society I'm going to give
Sean a 6 a strong 6 he just got a little
bit docked for me because you know we
need to see Sean the entire time we need
to see him stand up you know and and be
the hero that he is - this is hard this
is our stuff so I'm gonna give you a 6.5
wow that was a very soft
Wow wait a second wait a second wait a
second wait a second Wow is trowbridge
the new Simon of the group it's very
possible I've become too hard to bust I
think in this and do you have any
platforms Instagram to talk anything any
handles you want to share so that people
can find you fine Sean I use my name
just for Sean safety yeah as you should
we met a few seconds after me sorry I
did I'm not older sibling yeah but you
can find his comedy on at high on Molly
high on underscore Molly when the Molly
Clarke calm and then on tick-tock he's
also just loving the talk which is also
i underscore mauling who does it alright
well we just watched our last khaled
guys can now we have to pick a winner
I think I speak for everybody when I say
that nobody knows who's gonna win this
thing I'm actually legitimately
surprised by all the talents I don't
know about you guys like I feel very
untalented right now because of what
we've just seen but now is the time now
is the time to pick the first winner of
the BuzzFeed stay at home talent show
no joke I was not expecting how good all
of these people were going to be like we
were like oh yeah stay home challenge
that's what happens
everybody is incredibly talented and
incredibly passionate about about their
talents it's crazy it's really nice I
still feel talented anything I feel
emboldened to make this decision and I
know the decision we make is gonna be
the right one we are going to pick imeem
how crazy is that all these people are
so talented in these confined spaces I
know yeah just everything everything
from swinging to drum playing to making
food art like that was that was the
coolest for me and let us not forget
that the winner of the BuzzFeed counter
doesn't just get bragging rights they
get a sweat suit that said I won the
BuzzFeed talent show and all I got was
sweats and if you're not broadcasting
your accomplishments are you
accomplishing anything absolutely not
oh wait man hello Willie Willie how are
you I'm great an hour yo so we have
watched all the talents
how many talents and everybody was
really really good like it's I we all
sort of went into this thing being like
you know that'll be it'll be what it is
and and we'll have to do like most of
the work but really the talent has been
the star of the show the entire time
well before we get into all that you
know like I said like it's it's we're
just mulling over you know a couple
people and are so good so before I say
anything I want to say that like no
matter who wins this thing you are so
talented you are so talented you you
need to continue what you're doing and
people need to see you doing what you're
doing because it's I mean you saw me
last time I exploded the last time I saw
your town knock your face you know for
pete's sake so so before anything
happens I just want to let you know that
and and that it was an honor to watch
you perform the first winner of the
BuzzFeed stay at home talent show is
it's you baby it's you
we all got you with the build up but
it's you
it was always you Willie Willie
congratulations not only do you win the
title of the first-ever champion of the
stay home talent show you win a BuzzFeed
switz head to toe that's right perfect
for the summer weather very stylin you
get to wear it anywhere you want and
it's warm it's a it says the words I won
the Busby talent show and all I got was
these sweats congratulate you it was
very evident that not only are you very
talented we are very passionate about
your art and you're also using it for
the good of the world so we wanted to
commend you on that my friend thank you
thank you guys oh my god
really please we have we have to hear
from the champ please please tell us
what's going through your mind never in
a million years could I have expected
something like this to happen to me I
never would have expected this I I feel
proud of myself I really want to like
have the opportunity to share my gift
with the world that's all I wanted
wanted to do that's all I've been
wanting to do ever since I started
drumming so well now that you have the
mic is there anything you'd like to say
to the world or friends or family right
now anything at all I have the mic
friends don't give up on your dreams
don't give up on your talents don't give
up on your hobbies anything you want to
do if you really love it don't treat it
like a hobby treat it like your
lifestyle like make that your number one
priority aside from getting a job but
well our number one priority never give
up give up we keep grindin plug yourself
again my friend where can we find you on
the internet at Willie drummer
kid on instagram or at Willie dolt
drummer on tik-tok don't in the dope has
a three at the end instead of a eat
Willie dope drum
I love it thank you guys so much thank
you
Wow well that's it for our first-ever
BuzzFeed's
I can't it was an honor and a pleasure
judging people for you and it was an
honor to judge with you guys till next
time have a good and safe time doing
whatever it is that you're doing
rusty buddy you can show off your in
there weird